[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta dónde creéis
que hay más desigualdad económica en
sillicon valley o en burundi exacto la
respuesta es silicon valley
[Música]
pero vale esto no tiene por qué ser una
mala noticia para la gente que vive en
silicon valley por ejemplo imagina que
trabajas como ingeniero de sistemas para
las oficinas que tiene cisco en san josé
fácilmente puedes estar cobrando unos
siete mil quinientos dólares al mes no
está mal verdad bueno si te comparas con
tu amigo que trabaja como ingeniero de
software en google te vas a sentir como
un auténtico medio dijo una persona en
esta posición puede estar cobrando hasta
once mil dólares al mes y por supuesto
todo eso es una propina a comparado con
lo que puede ganar él o más
marck zuckerberg o cualquiera de los
multimillonarios que viven en esta zona
bueno
dicho de otra manera cualquiera se
sentiría como un pobre si tuviera como
vecino a las mayores fortunas del
planeta y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
con un sueldo de 150 mil dólares al año
yo también quiero sentirme pobre y
tenéis razón pero no todo es tan bonito
era una zona del mundo con tantísimo
dinero concentrado que creéis que ocurre
pues que los precios se ponen por las
nubes por ejemplo cuánto diríais que
cuesta un apartamento de dos
habitaciones en mountain view
[Música]
por si no lo sabéis mountain view es la
ciudad donde google tiene sus oficinas
centrales pero no penséis que es ninguna
gran metrópoli con poco más de 60 mil
habitantes tiene más o menos la misma
población que ávila por poner una
comparación pues bien cuanto diríais que
cuesta alquilar un apartamento de dos
habitaciones en mountain view 500
dólares mil dos mil pues atentos después
de haber buscado por internet lo más
barato que he encontrado estaba por tres
mil cuatrocientos dólares habéis oído
bien tres mil cuatrocientos dólares al
mes
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea las casas en
sillicon valley son un 60% más caras que
la media de todo eeuu y ya se lo que
estáis pensando hombre con un sueldo de
11 mil dólares al mes no me importaría
tener que pagar tres mil quinientos
dólares de alquiler verdad pues también
tenéis razón pero a ver por qué es
famoso silicon valley exacto por los
emprendedores es decir el atractivo de
silicon valley no es ir a trabajar para
facebook sino ser tú quien cree tu
propio facebook pero pensadlo bien
montar y aix una empresa en un sitio
donde los precios son tan caros
probablemente no y eso explica esta
noticia
[Música]
en la élite tecnológica de sillicon
valley está abandonando silicon valley
en manadas debido a la mentalidad
general y al precio de la vivienda tal
cual como lo es para que os hagáis una
idea en el año 2017 silicon valley tuvo
una inmigración neta negativa por
primera vez en décadas es decir que
había más gente marchándose que gente
llegando y esto es sorprendente si
tenemos en cuenta que esta zona del
mundo ha crecido a ritmos nacho
italianos desde los años 50 sin ir más
lejos en el año 1950 mountain view tenía
unos 6000 habitantes en 2017 tenía más
de 81.000 y lo mismo ha ocurrido con
todas las demás ciudades de esta zona
sin embargo según la encuesta la mitad
de los residentes asegura que está
pensando en marcharse debido a los
costes de vida y algunos ya lo han hecho
entre otros este señor que veis aquí
[Música]
y él deja silicon valley por los ángeles
para quien no lo sepa peter thiel es
algo así como el santa claus de silicon
valley
junto a él o más es uno de los
fundadores de paypal después se metió a
inversor de riesgo y podríamos decir que
es uno de los padrinos de facebook al
menos fue el primero que empezó a soltar
dinero cuando la empresa estaba todavía
en pañales
pero la pregunta es por qué hay tanta
gente abandonando silicon valley de
verdad el coste de vida es la principal
razón o hay algo más y lo que es más
importante es este el fin de silicon
valley tal y como lo conocemos hoy vamos
a responder a esta pregunta pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
no es país para emprendedores en otro
vídeo de visual política os contábamos
cómo se financia una startup en silicon
valley las rondas de financiación los
fondos de capital-riesgo etcétera
efectivamente silicon valley es el mejor
lugar del planeta para encontrar a gente
dispuesta a apostar por tu idea por otro
lado también es la disneylandia de la
mano de obra cualificada
si quieres montar una empresa de coches
automáticos necesitas contratar a gente
que tenga formación en las últimas
tecnologías
si vives en valladolid en españa' te va
a ser prácticamente imposible
encontrarlo sin embargo los mejores
talentos del mundo se reúnen en esta
área del planeta listos para hacer
negocios o ser contratados
el problema que esos talentos a los que
te gustaría contratar están demasiado
ocupados cobrando 150 mil dólares al año
en google y por muy fantástica que sea
tu startup es prácticamente imposible
competir con los sueldos y sobre todo la
estabilidad que te puede ofrecer un
gigante como google
como se supone que vas a empezar una
startup en un garaje si el garaje cuesta
millones de dólares pero aquí no termina
la cosa recordáis que california tiene
uno de los impuestos más altos de todo
eeuu pues la cosa no se queda aquí
[Música]
veréis en eeuu los estados no sólo
tienen autonomía para subir o bajar sus
propios impuestos también pueden elegir
cómo quieren cobrar los por ejemplo el
estado de texas no tiene impuesto sobre
la renta prácticamente todo lo que
recauda lo hace a través de impuestos
indirectos es decir impuestos que se
ponen a los precios de los bienes que
compramos pues bien california es todo
lo contrario a duras penas tiene
impuestos indirectos y casi toda la
recaudación viene de los sueldos de los
trabajadores y sobre todo de las rentas
del capital
[Música]
en otras palabras que si eres un
inversor y das beneficios altos un año
ya puedes ir preparando la cartera el
estado de california te va a cobrar
mucho más que cualquier otro y esto no
son buenas noticias si tenemos en cuenta
que silicon valley es en buena medida lo
que es gracias a los inversores de
capital riesgo sin embargo esta no es la
única razón
[Música]
i
por ejemplo peter thiel no se ha
marchado por los impuestos sino no se
habría ido a los ángeles que también
están en california lo cierto es que no
son pocos quienes dicen que silicon
valley está perdiendo gran parte de esa
diversidad que en su día fue la marca de
la casa
[Música]
silicon valley se ha convertido en un
estado de partido único básicamente
peter thiel apoyo a donald trump en la
campaña electoral y por lo visto este
tipo de cosas no se ven muy bien en
silicon valley y lo cierto es que el
silicon valley tiene muchas razones para
no tenerle cariño al presidente del país
ahora mismo vamos a ver por qué
[Aplausos]
h 1b recordáis que os decía que los
mayores talentos de todo el mundo se
concentran en silicon valley pues
oísteis bien dije el mundo el mundo
entero no sólo eeuu eso significa que el
57% de la gente que trabaja en las
empresas tecnológicas del valle sea de
origen extranjero es decir que hay más
inmigrantes que estadounidenses
[Música]
y como entran en el país tantos
inmigrantes pues muy sencillo con la ya
famosa visa h-1b básicamente se trata de
un visado que te permite trabajar en los
eeuu entre 3 y 6 años para tenerlo
necesitas que te contraté una empresa y
que justifique que tu trabajo es
especializado es decir que realmente
tienes unos conocimientos que te hacen
único y que te necesitan y por eso te
quieren contratar
si te echan de esa empresa tienes un mes
de plazo para encontrar otro trabajo si
no lo consigues te tienes que marchar
por supuesto esta visa la tiene que
solicitar la empresa que te contrata y
después el gobierno puede dártela o no
dártela además estas visas están
limitadas solo se pueden dar 65 mil al
año en todo eeuu y como ya os estaréis
imaginando buena parte de estas 65 mil
visas se las dan a los trabajadores que
emigran a silicon valley para que os
hagáis una idea sólo en el año 2016
google y apple contrataron a unas 5000
personas utilizando este proceso y en
fin creo que ya os podéis imaginar lo
que os voy a decir esto de la visa h-1b
no le hace la más mínima gracia a donald
trump
trump ordena que sea más difícil obtener
los visados h 1b no sé si os acordaréis
pero hace ya dos años básicamente cuando
donald trump juró el cargo sacamos este
vídeo donde os decíamos todos los
poderes que tiene el presidente de los
eeuu es decir qué cosas puede hacer sin
tener que pasarlo por el congreso pues
bien los controles de inmigración son
uno de esos poderes
pero no os equivoquéis si nos vamos a
los números
obama fue tan restrictivo con la
inmigración como lo pueda ser trump la
diferencia como siempre está en los
pequeños detalles y uno de esos pequeños
detalles es este visado h-1b y se trata
de algo que en silicon valley puede
suponer un auténtico problema
[Aplausos]
[Música]
silicon valley deja de contratar a
extranjeros para trabajos de tecnología
las ofertas de empleo caen en un 37% por
miedo a los controles de inmigración de
donald trump según dicen varios medios
de comunicación muchas de estas empresas
tecnológicas podrían abrir nuevas
oficinas en países como canadá donde es
más fácil contratar inmigrantes pero
todavía es difícil ver lo que va a
ocurrir una cosa es lo que se dice y
otra es lo que se hace sin embargo la
pregunta a la que sí podemos responder
ahora es y si no es silicon valley cuál
será la nueva capital tecnológica del
mundo pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
de palo alto a shenzhen si buscas en
google descubriréis que casi cualquier
ciudad del mundo quiere convertirse en
el nuevo silicon valley basta con que un
periodista encuentre un puñado de
programadores trabajando en un mismo
espacio de coworking para que se lance a
escribir un artículo titulado el silicon
valley de inserción y nombre de ciudad
por ejemplo en muchos medios se cita a
berlín como un hub de creación de
startups incluso el gobierno alemán ha
abierto oficinas en silicon valley para
que los emprendedores de este país
puedan encontrar inversores pero lo
cierto es que casi ninguna empresa ha
conseguido seducir a estos grandes
fondos de inversión californianos al
menos por ahora
así que la pregunta es cómo sabemos si
una ciudad se está convirtiendo de
verdad en una capital tecnológica pues
bien hay varias formas de medirlo
la primera sería contar el número de
unicornios que han nacido en este lugar
y os preguntaréis qué es un unicornio
pues un unicornio es una startup que
llega a valer más de mil millones de
dólares en el año 2017 hubo 57 startups
que se convirtieron en unicornios pues
bien de esas 57 startups 18 no eran de
eeuu sino de china exacto hablamos de
empresas como de jotas que fabrican
drones o alibaba de la que ya hemos
hablado aquí en visual político y eso
explica titulares como éste
[Música]
el último mercado emergente de china el
capital riesgo por ejemplo sequoia
capital es un fondo de capital riesgo
nacido en sillicon valley que ya ha
abierto varias oficinas en china y ya se
lo que estáis pensando significa esto
que china va a eclipsar eeuu pues
otras ciudades como mumbai en la india o
tel aviv en israel también están
atrayendo muchísimo dinero de capital
riesgo
o suene una empresa que se llama weeks
se trata de un servicio para crear
páginas web fácilmente pues bien esta
empresa está fundada en israel israel
apenas cuenta con unicornios pero supone
más del 2 por ciento de todo el dinero
que se mueve en todo el capital riesgo
en el planeta
no parece mucho pero es una auténtica
barbaridad si tenemos en cuenta que
israel entero tiene menos población que
la ciudad de nueva york en resumen que
no hay ninguna alternativa clara a
silicon valley es más a día de hoy
incluso con toda esa gente que se está
marchando silicon valley sigue captando
más de la mitad del dinero que se
invierte en startups en todo el mundo y
lo más probable es que siga manteniendo
un enorme protagonismo en este sector
cuál es la diferencia entonces bueno
pues que ahora hay más lugares donde
también se pueden sacar grandes ideas
adelante dicho de otra forma hace 30
años si tenías una buena idea y ganas de
hacerla crecer prácticamente solo había
un lugar donde podías hacerlo ahora
tienes más y eso siempre es una buena
noticia nos parece
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es creéis que
silicon valley ha llegado a su tope y se
quedará como está sin seguir creciendo o
este éxodo será algo pasajero
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si queréis
también podéis visitar nuestra página de
patrián para apoyar este proyecto y si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]